problema número 210 el fabricante de un
televisor produce 600 unidades por mes
con un costo de 90 por unidad y todas
las unidades producidas se venden cada
mes cuál es el precio de venta promedio
mínimo por unidad necesario para
garantizar que al venderse todas las
unidades sea al menos de 42.000
buscamos el precio de venta mínimo
llamemos a stop el precio por unidad y a
esto le vamos a restar el costo de
producción le quitamos 90 y esto que es
por unidad tenemos que multiplicarlo por
el número de unidades que se producen
que son 600 y esto tiene que ser de al
menos 42.000 mayor o igual que 42.000
vamos a factorizar esto 600 pp por 600 p
es 600 p menos 90 x 600 va a ser igual a
54 mil menos 54 mil que es mayor o igual
a 42 mil sumamos 54 mil en ambos lados y
nos va a quedar 600 p 42 mil más 5
y 4000 nos va a dar 96 mil esto es mayor
o igual a 96 mil el sentido de la
desigualdad no va a cambiar porque estoy
agregando números positivos y para
simplificar lo vamos a dividir todo
entre 100 600 entre 100 va a ser 6 p y
esto es mayor o igual a 96 mil entre 100
va a ser igual a 960 finalmente voy a
dividir todo entre 6 me va a quedar p
mayor o igual 960 entre 6 va a ser 160 y
este es el precio mínimo de venta por
unidad que es nuestra opción de
siguiente problema problema número 211
si 4x + 3g es igual a menos 2 y 3 x más
6 es igual a cero cuál es el valor de y
bueno aquí tenemos dos ecuaciones y de
hecho voy a usar una de las ecuaciones
para sustituir en la otra de esta
ecuación yo voy a despejar x y para
hacerlo tengo que restar 6 en ambos
lados
a quedar 3x es igual a menos seis
dividido todo entre tres y me va a
quedar que x es igual a menos 2 y ahora
que ya conozco x lo voy a sustituir en
la primera ecuación de manera que me
queda 4 x x como x es menos 24 x menos
dos más tres porque igual a menos dos y
ahora lo resuelvo 4 x menos 2 va a ser
igual a menos 8 más 13 igual a menos 2
ahora sumamos 8 en ambos lados y nos va
a quedar 3 igual a 8 menos 26 muy bien y
ahora voy a dividir todo entre 3 de
manera que me va a quedar que ya es
igual a 2 y esta es mi opción el
siguiente problema problema número 212
los conjuntos de datos 1 2 y 3 se deben
ordenar de mayor a menor desviación
estándar aquí están los conjuntos y
recordemos que la desviación estándar
indica que tan lejos están los números
del conjunto con respecto a la media en
todos estos casos la media 74 a
excepción del número 3 en la segunda
opción la desviación estándar es cero
porque todos los elementos son iguales
así que tiene la desviación estándar más
chica sólo nos falta ver cuál de 13
tiene la siguiente desviación estándar
más pequeña del conjunto 1 creamos que
la media 74 pero cuál es la diferencia
bueno del 72 al 74
hay dos unidades de diferencia de 73 a
la unidad del 75 al 74 ayuno y de 76 a
74 hay dos unidades
queremos que el 74 no tiene diferencia
esta es la magnitud de la diferencia
sacamos el promedio de esta diferencia 2
+ 13 + 1 426 y lo dividimos entre 5
números esto es igual a 6 quintos
ahora tenemos que ver cuál es la
desviación estándar del conjunto 3 vamos
a encontrar primero cuál es el promedio
así que sumamos 62 más 89 y me va a dar
9 más 2 11 8 614 más una 15 151 más aquí
tengo tres números 74 3 x 74 y esto es
igual a 151 más 3 por 74 3 por 4 12 7
por 3 21 más 122 ahora sumamos todo esto
y nos va a dar igual a 2 más 135 272 más
una 3 373 y bueno ahora a este número
todavía nos falta dividirlo entre 5 para
que podamos tener el promedio 77 por 5
35 37 menos 35 es igual a 2 bajo el 34
por 5 20 23 menos 20 3
pongo punto decimal para poder bajar un
0 6 por 5 30 30 menos 30 es 0 y aquí
tengo mi división exacta por lo que mi
promedio de este tercer conjunto es 74.6
ahora sí veamos cuál es la diferencia de
s 74.6 con todos los elementos del
conjunto 3
veamos 74.6 menos 62 es igual a punto 6
un 12.6 muy bien 12.6
la diferencia del siguiente es punto 6
ese también es punto 6 este otro también
es punto 6 y ahora 89 74.6 cuánto nos va
a dar
4 4 y 1 14.4 y a ojo podemos darnos
cuenta que aquí la diferencia es más
grande por lo que la desviación estándar
va a ser mayor y ahora ya podemos
ordenar nuestros conjuntos de mayor a
menor nos va a quedar primero el 3 luego
el 1 y al final el 2 y esta combinación
es nuestra opción de siguiente problema
problema número 213 cuál de los
siguientes es el menor entero positivo
que es divisible entre todos estos
números 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 9 bueno tratamos
de minimizar nuestros factores si el
número es divisible entre 8 no tendremos
que preocuparnos por los factores 2 y 4
el 8 ya los incluye y si es divisible
entre 9 no nos vamos a preocupar del 3
por que igual ya está incluido en el 9
el 7 no tiene factores el 6 si el número
divisible entre 9 y 8 entonces ya están
incluidos los números 2 y 3 así que el 6
lo puedo quitar y finalmente el 5 pues
no tiene factores lo tengo que incluir
los factores que nos quedan son vamos a
escribirlos aparte 5 7 8 y 9 y al
multiplicar los que nos va a quedar 8
por 9 es igual a 72 72 por 7 nos va a
dar 500 4 por 5 que es el que sigue 5
por 4 20 5 por 0 0 pongo el 2 5 por 5 25
me va a quedar 2.520 que es nuestra
opción se nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo